одним з головних моїх завдань
перебування в парламенті є захищати
українські інформаційний простір
захищати українську мову Я думав що це
моє завдання вже виконано після 24
лютого Я вірю що ми всі здатні справді
об'єднатися для того щоб робити цю
країну українською Тому що тільки
українська Україна стоїть проти
російської агресії але зараз знову
повертається русифікація в цей зал мені
соромно що в той час коли наші Захисники
зі зброєю в руках захищають Україну Ми
садимо їм в спину ножа русифікації саме
таким є цей закон він нас гарно
позначений законопроект європейським
прапорцем вперед коденному там має бути
три колор а не європейський прапор саме
під європейським прапором хочуть
зменшити квоту української музики на
радіо хочуть щоб ви всі хто скучили за
на рожистами на українських екранах
могли знов вдовольнитися вони знову
з'являться на екранах пам'ятаєте як ми з
вами тішили За що ми врешті ухвалили
закон який передбачає що в Україні
неможливі виступи російських виконавців
в Україні неможливо прослуховувати їхні
фонограми зараз після ухвалення цього
законопроекту цей закон просто в топку
він припиняє свою дію його нема це -
русифікація і хто сказав що є що мені ви
то затуляємо останні шпаринки для
русского мира - ні ви вивалюйте двері
русского мира в Україну не допустіть
цього навіть в першому читанні вас
обманюють На жаль цей законопроект
робить Україну слабшою не підтримуйте
його навіть в першому читанні Слава
Україні